uh
can i touch the flower though
stop
hello
before video begins if you haven't
bought christmas gift yet now's your
chance because we got the k1 pro baby
look at this beautiful yes
the tambourine combo as well god damn
this thing is huge
oh look at that oh beautiful all right
cool got a menu free extended warranty
nice nice
quick start that's for losers
dude it looks
so good so this is acrylic
it looks amazing so all the keycaps are
removable and all the custom one look at
that boom fits perfectly i have the old
version here
boom
so with this pro version ghost has taken
a lot of feedback and made some serious
upgrades from the new one
a lot of it i gotta be honest i don't
understand but apparently it's important
it's got hot swappable five pin pcb that
means that the customer can change the
included switches with any switch they
want on the market afterwards okay no
that's cool i get that and the keyboard
comes with gateron switches okay listen
i gotta be honest i'm all about the
aesthetic the light bleeds through it
backlight mode switch there it is oh
damn that looks good i'm actually hyped
is that not the best looking keyboard
it's got underglow and there's 34
dedicated rgb leds under the pcb so you
can customize all of it i think there's
magnets here so if you want to have an
armrest it snaps in there's five magnets
embedded in the keyboard two of them
connect to the wrist yeah and three are
meant for additional accessories called
snappies oh yeah
you can put accessories
accessory magnets on them that's so cool
we also included acoustic foam between
the pcb and the plate to make the
keyboard sound more acoustically
pleasing well let's hear it
[Music]
i might be biased but greatest keyboard
alright let's check out the tambourine
this is what everyone wants to know so
if you get the tambourine combo
[Music]
the tambourine combo comes with a mouse
the same gorgeous keyboard
the custom keycap
and the extra bonus
majiggers
however
this is a limited edition once they're
sold out there's no more of these
keyboards will arrive before christmas
if you order it before the 18th of
december so make sure you do that
they're available in usa canada europe
and united kingdom right now there's an
early bird deal so if you get it right
now the price is 159.99
which it means from now and three days
of this video being published make sure
that you use that offer and yeah i hope
you guys enjoy the new keyboard and all
the feedback that we took on it through
the acrylic
all right i'll stop simping thank you
ghost keyboard you did an amazing job
let's get on with the video good
morning gamers
welcome back
i've been playing a little bit on the
new update i haven't i've done some cool
changes isn't that right bonkish monkey
oh wait you're donkey wait who's bonky
then
who are you
who
hey
oh i'm writing him a tradition
all right
well anyway
i'm fine
i thought today we're gonna explore
what's actually new in the update last
episode was a big disappointment but
there are lush caves and cool stuff look
there's axolotls they're chilling
they're still doing well all right we're
gonna enter the nether and we're gonna
walk really far because apparently only
the new update spawn in like areas you
haven't been in before so we'll have to
just travel really far this is a my net
i don't think i ever showed this
because i want it to be a big reveal but
uh there you go
which way should i go this way i think
this goes to furthers i forgot to bring
obsidian god god damn it shut up
you're alive
wow i don't care
she could be dead honestly i didn't even
remember she existed
all right where do i store obsidian now
where
yeah monkey
where do i
stand there you go maybe we should grab
some name tag now i just need steel and
then we should be good to go i have a
few steals just a couple all right we're
officially ready to go
just for good luck
i didn't have to do that i just i needed
to do that sometimes you have to do that
all right here we go this is really my
favorite part of minecraft is
running
and i didn't carp at this area i haven't
even laid it out it's pathetic at least
i did safety on it yeah this works i
didn't have to make it so fancy watch me
fall off a cliff when it ends there it
is okay
i think this goes to another castle we
could keep going i think yeah
oh god so slow
what if we instead just go this way see
what we find and take from there
i got new recipes from basalt okay
we're setting up our uh portal here
there we go now we should enter an area
that we've never been to before
boom
here we go loading terrain that's good
that's good take your time minecraft to
make something cool something up
the hell is this
i hear chicken we must have been near
surface
okay maybe new lush cave the hell is
this
really a burst a birch bio
i'm gonna have to build a tower because
i'm never gonna find myself back
there we go oh my god i'm in the middle
alpaca is that new that that could be
near that's that yeah wow
yeah
what's up alpacas have you seen the new
lush caves
cool huh
where'd he go no one saw anything huh
what what that's crazy
[Music]
i want dark sven back
my mojang
lush caves
so we're looking for the new trees
they're supposed to be new trees
they have little things on them where
are the new trees there's a village
maybe they've seen the new trees
hello
hello fellow travelers
have you seen
the new treats the new biomes
[Music]
why does everyone ignore me what uh what
a nice quaint little town that was i'll
uh i'll be sure to come back someday
to thank them
oops uh
let's see if we can find the new tree we
got a jungle biome here
this is kind of random like
what
and what this is a super rare biome what
the
huh
that's weird
it looks pretty okay well i never seen
this bio mixed with snow maybe that's
just me it's kind of sick and it's like
a mountain too
okay i get it it's almost like you
should remake your entire world because
now yeah look it's way more cliff here
that's kind of sick okay i'm starting to
get it i'm sorry for complaining
minecraft it's just you killed my dog
yeah it's it's your fault
why is there no dog armor mojang okay
you gave us cliffs where's the dog armor
whoa
so this is the power of the new update
huh you can fly in this old cool little
it's quite a substantial difference here
in the new areas it looks way different
is that is that a lush game i found it i
found the lush game boy
there it is i found it
yes
that's so cool okay hype hype in the
chat let's go i didn't think i would
actually find it to be honest
oh they lit up ah they got chains
what that's so cool oh gotta be careful
here there there's the new tree i found
the smallest baby version give me my axe
okay well it died
are these the new
azalea
there we go moss block
oh
they're like weirdly carpeted
that's so cool
oh there's another tree kill it
yeah
it's so cool with the chains going on
here too oh god it's getting dark
uh i hope the warden doesn't oh yes
i gotta be careful here this is
dangerous okay i do want one of these
ah i got it i got it glowberries
that's so cool if i
oh
i forget just how far i can fall since i
have
everything
that would have killed me if i didn't
have all the armor jesus christ let's be
careful here this is unexplored
territory what is that just
oh this is very dangerous
i made that sound that moms make when
you break a bit too much
even though you're clearly totally fine
oh god this is so pretty
whoa
whoa they're everywhere
i love them i see it now
i see what they were trying to do
so cool
i'm terrified dude
oh no no no i don't think so mr creeper
saying
dude one shot it let's go is that the
whoa this is so cool yes i found the
flower can i lit this on fire i feel
like i should be able to
no
whoa whoa whoa
let's take it easy here okay i don't
know where they're coming from
all right i i don't mess with this
poisonous spider dude look at this
though it's gorgeous
i love it i see you
all the chains too this is so pretty
this is the prettiest update
man maybe not the nether update was
pretty okay let's check out those i want
those what is this
nothing what is this
oh it's clay
insane
i love it okay this is dangerous though
we gotta make sure i wanna get the new
flower where was it there there oh gosh
smooth baby okay how do i grab it maybe
with the hoe
i got it i got it i want more of them
can i grab it by hand
you can okay there's a spawner i see it
kind of want to kill it cause i hate
them so much
am i hitting it
okay i got it
nice like when i go real quiet this one
is actually dangerous
okay nice
doing good
all right
hey
check this out
yeah baby
let's go
look at this how cool is this
oh this is dangerous oh god i almost
died uh
can i touch the flower though
stop
okay got it too nice maybe i should be a
little bit more cat maybe
nah okay maybe
okay all right i'm gonna float down now
oh that was sick
oh they got these
the jump pads
nice
so these are for parkour i think like
you jump on them but eventually they
fall down
i don't know if they reset but it's kind
of sick
hey
god they are the archers never stop
getting annoying do they
they actually do a lot of damage what
the hell let's put on the actual armor
jesus
me
this is dangerous
glow squids in here
why did that one archer do so much
damage he must have had a sick bow or
something i want these
did you see the uh the squid look at how
pretty
they really went for uh hey let's make
everything pretty
[Music]
god damn it i am such a tank for
creepers though
damn dude look at that that's so cool
you're dead though but you know
[Music]
love it so pretty oh dude it keeps going
down it's insane whoa
they got too look another one
bro you spawn in a bad place didn't you
i'm just gonna float down
clean
this is huge
huge cave
oh whoa whoa it just keeps going minus
31 what i'm super far down no wonder
that's so cool
i'm so amazed by everything is that
diamond
wow i love diamond
yeah baby
oh damn huge block 15 nice do i need it
absolutely not oh we're down deep boys
minus 51 baby but there's still plants
here that's so cool
i take no chances nowadays huh
damn that creeper barely
put a dent in this stone it's so much
harder
dude how many creepers jesus
scott gopher
come
i'm just gonna grab more resources and
then i think i'm gonna head back
there it is
it's time to head back home games
successful
minecraft exploration
that's what i'm talking about
thank you mojang very cool
hey look who it is the most useless cat
in the universe
just stare yeah keep guarding the gate
make sure no one goes through otherwise
you're fired
i guess the problem with this update is
that everything looks like pretty and
nice and uh happy as everything in my
base really looks evil and
menacing and
daunting i don't really know what to do
with like this new stuff
oh maybe i can put in my glass house oh
that'll look good this is one of the
first things i built oh this would look
great my beehive okay
looks like i can't place them god damn
it okay
uh what about okay
yeah sure oh that's kind of fun you can
make like a little parkour to grab the
grab the b yeah sure that's fun everyone
loves fun here all right let's plant
these whatever these are
i don't get it
and then we get the spore can i place
those oh that's kind of sick i did not
expect that
[Music]
cool
that looks pretty
okay not bad
well anyway
thanks for watching this episode of
minecraft if you enjoyed smash like uh
subscribe
oh cool you can see the llama from here
okay i wanted to make it like uh it
seemed like we're powered by these
planets
and stuff anyway i'm still working on it
it's pretty sick
i'm excited
all right see you tomorrow bye